[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est
les 7h39 du match puisqu'on mai
7h40 du match le temps passe vite pour
vous parler de ce smartphone là
aujourd'hui je les tester je vais
essayer de tout les côtés
j'ai fait plutôt d'un mec et surtout
beaucoup beaucoup de photos c'est le
samsung galaxy s ii ultra c'est très
très bon modèle alors on va parler bien
évidemment des zones où l on va parler
du est devant la presse du régime
influence on va regarder un peu de ça
sur la question virage mais aujourd'hui
on va tromper sur le s20 ultra et ont
fait depuis ici times square
[Musique]
regardez là il ya des travaux tous les
côtés à new york
ils nous refont un peu visés et puis ça
construit ne sais pas s'il y en a un et
sinon si ça se fait pas mais dans le
quartier vous montez un peu plus haut
vers un centre alpa a construit de tous
les côtés
[Musique]
mec
première chose dont je vous parlais au
niveau du smartphone et son design alors
il a un design un peu atypique il est
assez lourd qu'on fait
ce qui fait que contient assez bien nos
mains on peut quasiment faire le tout
avec une seule main ça c'est assez
pratique mais il est très très grand il
est assez lourd il est assez massif
comme smartphone qui pèse quelque chose
comme 220 grammes ce qui globalement
n'est pas rien et lorsque vous le mettez
sur vous dans une poche de pantalon
il prend beaucoup de place et il est pas
se regarder là je le glisse comme ça à
vaguer alors manger au mcdo renaître
dans ma poche il ya tendance un petit
peu toujours un peu a dépassé et enfin
si vous comparez par rapport à un iphone
11 pro mac ce et bien voyez il est plus
au large de cale pieds avec mes doigts
il est plus haut que l'iphone on se
promet axe il est un poil moins large
un tout petit peu moins large mais
encore plus haut c'est pas notre cas
c'est ma s'est passé il faut vraiment le
savoir si vous voulez un petit
smartphone si vous avez des petites
poches voulait pas truqué des passereaux
clermont celui là il n'est pas fait pour
nous si par contre vous les deux choses
qui tient bien en main moi j'ai pas des
mains de ses pas d'émail normes si vous
vous quelque chose qui se tient très
bien en main vous aurez absolument aucun
souci parfaitement tape de ce côté là
donc le format je trouve à six trous
maintenant il ya un autre truc c'est au
niveau du design c'est le poinçon
j'aurais espéré que cette année ça nous
sommes nous supprime ce petit poisson et
qu'on se retrouve avec une caméra
intégrée sous l'écran peut-être pour
2021 ce n'est pas le cas pour 2020 à
côté de cela des portes sont extrêmement
fin de tous les côtés ce qui fait que ça
le rend quasiment invisible on a un
menton qui est extrêmement léger très
très faim pendant qu'alain global qui
est vachement bien toute la surface
avant sert quasiment d'écran nous parce
que tout petit point sont
du point de vue design général que
samsung a fait un plutôt bon taf
ça c'est très très gros mais bon on se
calme et tu pourquoi pas toute façon
tous les smartphones aujourd'hui doivent
intégrer des gros module caméra
insolence vous allez mettre une coque de
protection vous allez faire disparaître
c'est partir d'ailleurs parlons aussi
puisque vous parle de coques de
protection pensez vraiment une protégée
grâce à mon partenaire rhinochill vidéo
réalisée bien évidemment en partenariat
avec rhino chez d'alors il ya pas mal de
solutions portée j'allais vraiment parce
que autant le smartphone je me trouve
très très cool autant il ya un côté un
peu glissant et je craque même si assez
indo qui est protégé vous risquez
d'endommager et surtout cette partie
dallas qui dépasse quand même vous voyez
elle dépasse ce qui fait que s'il prend
des mauvais shoots
j'aurais vraiment parvenir à vider je
vous conseille de solides la première
c'est le prendre la crasse garde ça ça
vient vous protéger ça vient vous
l'entouré pourquoi quand même de votre
smartphone mais par contre elle a quand
même le protéger et ça c'est plutôt pas
mal donc ça la licra je garde c'est la
première solution dont je joue pas et
que surtout ça et que je ronge
mon matos à des petites boîtes tout le
monde se lève va au travail en entendant
le new york y travaillent pas preneur
pourrissent ticas toxiques qui
globalement est pas ma deuxième solution
c'est la coque de protection c'est la
solide suite de rhinau chine vous prenez
vous le mettez ce qui est pas mal ce
vous protège tout le dos directement
s'il prend un shoot pourquoi pas
pourquoi l'avouer donc ces deux
solutions vous avez un code de réduction
en scène dans la description vous avez
tous les détails en bas vous pouvez y
aller tous ont profité d'une excellente
protection un meilleur prix merci kirino
chine merci monsieur
[Musique]
coli
mais dont on peut faire que ça me fait
extrêmement soirée devant tout le monde
maîtrise ils sont vraiment extrême
enfants c'est la qualité de leurs écrans
vous avez une dague j'ai absolument
incroyable de gens en termes de taille
c'est une dalle de 6,1 pouces dynamique
un oled 3d hd 3200 pixels par une 1440
pixels le truc est énorme
il ya 500 ans pixels par pouce enfin ce
n'est pas ce truc c'est absolument
dingue que ce soit les contrastes des
couleurs la luminosité les noir absolu
touquet vraiment énorme et en plus de ça
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement de
100 meilleurs ça va vous me direz à quoi
sert un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz et bien c'est tout simplement
lorsque vous allez venir
crowley parce que ça va bouger dans
l'image ça va être lui très nette à pas
devenir un petit peu flou lorsque ça va
bouger vite ça apporte beaucoup de
confort au visionnage lorsque vous allez
naviguer et également lorsque vous allez
jouer à des jeux pour une expérience de
gimme vous avez un écran qui est
absolument incroyable pour une
expérience de visionnage c'est la même
chose que ce soit pour regarder des
films des séries jouer et faire ce que
vous voulez toute la journée vous avez
un truc est vraiment complètement
optimisé et ça c'est vraiment des très
très très gros atout de ce sport
toute façon on va pas se mentir samsung
fournit des dalles pour beaucoup de
smartphones du marché
leur réputation n'est plus à faire si
vous voulez un smartphone avec une dalle
extrêmement bien calibré d'excellente
qualité
vous allez sur une dalle samsung vous
serez pas déçus c'est vrai dans le
milieu de gamme et dans le haut de gamme
et le très haut de gamme là ça devient
carrément exceptionnel le sens vers vous
allez vraiment le voir comme ça lorsque
vous allez tenir ce rôle et je sais pas
si ça va être vraiment évident pour vous
le voir au travers de la caméra parce
qu'on n'est pas ce sens inverse lorsque
je suis en train de filmer lorsque je le
diffuse mais ça apporte beaucoup
beaucoup de fluidité vaut presque eu
quasiment lire comme ça alors je dis
presse ne sait quand même pas hyper
évident mais c'est très fluide pour la
navigation c'est vraiment génial et la
qualité de cette dalle pour me regarder
du contenu multimédia c'est génial là
moi je suis en 18 9e on n'est pas sur un
18 lyon mais surtout ce qui est un petit
peu plus long mais ça fait franchement
le taf vous venez légèrement croquer
comme ça ça marche vraiment des on a une
qualité d'alc est vraiment incroyable ça
pour me regarder du contenu multimédia
des films des séries tout ce que vous
voulez c'est un écran qui est vraiment
top
il ya effectivement toute cette partie
d'écran qui est bien mais lorsque vous
voulez côté une expérience multimédia ce
que c'est important d'avoir une bonne
qualité audio parce que si vous avez un
son qui équipe aussi vous avez un bel
écran et bah c'est pas ce que c'est ça
et par contre là dessus s'absout nous a
fait aussi un super boulot au niveau de
l'audio alors ici pas de prise jack
malheureusement sur cette île prologis
smartphone l'atf d'attenté soit d'avoir
un petit adaptateur soin d'eux d'avoir
un casque avec une connexion bluetooth
parce que vous êtes du bluetooth 5.0 là
dessus ça marche merveilleusement bien
la latence est extrêmement faible ça va
très très bien produit des films et des
séries je fais du bruit parce qu'ici à
new york et des travaux de tous les
côtés d'un bruit monstrueux par contre
il ya un son stéréo qui est vraiment
cool hein qui vient du haut parleur qui
situé en bas ici sont la tranche et le
deuxième qui vient du haut parleur d'ici
et je trouve que il ya particulièrement
déséquilibre lorsque vous regardez
quelque chose comme ça avec votre
smartphone à la main et bien la
sensation d'immersion il ya un son qui
est bien sûr tout vous avez un gros
volume sonore que vous faire réécouter
vous allez voir le truc
une fois que tout ça est prendre autres
parenthèses à cause du son mais ça
marche
jean françois gillet la leçon qu'il
gagnera c'est immersif vous écouter
depuis new york pas forcément évident
vous rencontrent les croyez moi sur
parole
[Musique]
oui
au couvent et sac à dos c'est quand même
plutôt cool c'est la performance vous
avez un exynos 990 couplé à 12 ian rams
a fait le taf
ça ira pas aussi loin que ce que vous
allez voir avec la version
nord-américaine de ce produit parce que
pour les yeux et écoutez madame vous
avez un stade rigaud de 865 fois plus
performant que ce que vous allez voir
annexe 2 990 mais déjà avec alex 1990
pour un usage courant que ce soit pour
visionner les vidéos naviguer sur
internet faire des photos tandis que
voulaient les capacités de calcul sont
très très bonne donc y aura pas de souci
là dessus vous mesurerez pas la
différence vous pourrez mesurer la
différence par rapport à sa dragonne 865
steve rey a osé venir pousser dans ses
retranchements en allant le plus loin
possible avec vraiment du multitâche
mais globalement je suis patient voyez
vraiment la différence en termes de
performance atteint autonomie ça parce
que c'est probablement à pas grand chose
mais ça fait le taf
vous avez de l'argent vous à une version
128 go de stockage soit 512 ya de
stockage dans les deux cas extensible
jusqu'à un terrain c'est plutôt cool
déjà 100 réfugiés de stockage à fait
apte à les pendre mais les gréements
après de vous une façon pour ça il faut
l'anticiper vous parle d'état risque
dans quelques instants liés à ces deux
versions à partir de
et globalement si plutôt bas on est très
grosse batterie de 5000 millan terreur
c'est la plus grosse batterie qu'on
puisse avoir pour l'instant sur un
modèle de sainte soulle ça fait tâche
c'est compliqué de parler d'autonomie
parce que ça dépend des usages ça dépend
ce que vous vous allez en faire mais je
dirais que sur un usage un petit peu
standard vous pouvez le tenir deux jours
c'est de gagner autonomie vous descendez
vous restez pas ans en arrière vous
pourrez gagner légèrement si vous voulez
gagner aussi en autonomie vous venez ce
multi vous passez sur le dark mode sur
when you avec deux top le mans parce que
vous aurez avoir des pixels noirs avec
depuis que ces noirs sont des pixels et
un permettra de gagner un petit peu à
l'autonomie bon ça c'est du point de
détail c'est vraiment cher et de
l'optimisation moi votre smartphone nous
et pouvons garder deux jours sans
problème et ça c'est plutôt cool il faut
savoir aussi que si vous avez un
chargeur de 25 watts
si vous permet de le recharger quand
même globalement assez rapidement sous
battery 2,5 millions terreur si vous les
recharger pas rapidement vous allez
passer désormais la charge et 25 watts
et principal chargeur le plus rapide
qu'on pourrait avoir sur le marché mais
je dirais que dans l'ensemble vu sa
configuration safra le taf et pour toute
la partie spec je vous renvoie à ma
vidéo de présentation vont à toutes les
informations sur le samsung galaxy s 20
ultra est légalement les autres
témoignages bons soins des mères des
bébés
du mois c'est évidemment là dessus vous
avez de la 5g alors l'a5 josé pas
forcément besoin vous aujourd'hui d'un
abonnement son smartphone 5g parce que
la scène j'ai commencé à arriver kelly
pas encore partout mais si vous le
voulez vous pouvez avoir et ça c'est
plutôt cool donc la 5g c'est possible
dès maintenant vous avez du wifi 6 pour
vous connecter très très rapidement en
fibres et en optimiser complètement
votre connexion vous et bien évidemment
du nfc pour le paiement dématérialisé on
doit payer avec samsung paye donc ça
c'est cool je vous les aidez bluetooth
5.0 pour venir à paris notamment vocal
axis buzz plus on va se tester d'ici
quelques jours donc je vous en
reparlerai vous invite donc à place à
bout tous les côtés je invite donc à
vous abonner si c'est pas déjà qu'un un
smartphone j'ai le secret en plein coeur
un smartphone que certaines questions
ip68 donc et résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière de tranquille qui peut
accueillir une double signe donc ça
c'est cool si vous êtes frontaliers vous
êtes donc de quartier ou alors vous avez
une semi pro et perso
[Musique]
gros poisson smartphones se situe ici à
l'arrière au niveau de sa caméra et
notamment au niveau de la petite
dernière ici que vous permet d'avoir un
zoom jusqu'à poisson c'est écrit là vous
pouvez monter avec un zoom jusqu'à 300
alors est-ce que ce zoom x s'en sert à
quelque chose voir absolument rien du
tout mais c'est ce qu'on va essayer de
voir maintenant ce que vous avez dans
votre applique d'appareils photos ya pas
mal de choses à savoir et il ya eu un
très très très gros boulot logiciel qui
a été fait là dessus alors attendez sur
le mode nuit j'en sors il ya vraiment
des très très très belles innovations
dont une en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
appelle le mode single take alors mode
single take il est génial c'est que par
exemple vous allez prendre ça comme ça
je vous montre enfin une petite démo en
live ça me faire une vidéo je me mets
sur le côté je filme un petit peu de
tous les côtés je vais filmer bon bah il
ya des passants c'est mieux si vous le
faites sur quelqu'un sur un de vos posts
est beaucoup plus simple vous bougez
vous pouvez venir ajouté
et voilà en ce que ça va faire le single
take ça vous proposer une photo vous y
retrouvez ici avec différentes
possibilités donc là en haut j'ai ma
photo ça c'est ma photo de bassa ça
marche ensuite bien évidemment ça va
générer une vidéo c'est la vidéo j'ai
tourné vous l'avez vu ça ça marche ça
nous aussi générer une photo en noir et
blanc est vachement cool et voyez j'ai
tous mes petits aperçus en bas ensuite
je vais avoir une petite vidéo en
accéléré qui est assez assez rigolote
fassel à capteur principal avec l'autre
là ça mais là zoom et ça m'a changé un
peu la colorimétrie celle là là l'autre
eh bien ça me fait un espèce d'avant en
arrière
si je comprends bien ça me fait une
espèce de boucle en fait avant arrière
enfin vous voyez là ça va générer
quelques photos alors l'idée du single
take c'est qu'en fait tous les objectifs
vont tourner en même temps que ce soit
le grand angle ultra grand-angle le
téléobjectif ça me permettra à la fin de
proposer quelque chose de vraiment
particulier
et en plus ce mode là il est vachement
intelligent parce que si vous souhaitez
par exemple un gros amis ça va
reconnaître que c'est une personne ça va
pouvoir vous proposez donc bien
évidemment à partir de la vidéo une
photo aux standards une photo avec le
mode portrait un truc est vraiment
génial et ça pour moi ça on est très
très gros point fort en termes de photos
et de vidéos ce smartphone parce que
c'est très simple vous voulez shooter un
petit truc et ça vous propose pas mal de
choses ça c'est cool
ensuite vous avez la partie photo bon
sens et la partie photo je dirais un
petit peu standard avec plusieurs
possibilités
le capteur principal que vous allez
avoir comme ça vous allez pouvoir venir
zoomer et regarder en bas là c'est
facile x 1 x 2 x 4 x 10 x 30 hop je me
remets la fois 30 et jusqu'à fois sans
sur le foin ça fait le taff garder foi 2
le souk assez impressionnant le x 4 ça
marche en faites-vous
mais jusqu'en x 10 cents absolument
aucune perte de qualité dans le x 10
s'est stabilisé c'est ouf de chez ouf
on va ensuite sur le x 30 vous allez
chercher vachement loin et dès que vous
arrivez sur le fatras en gardez vous
avez ce petit viseur il vous permet de
savoir où est ce que vous êtes
ou est-ce que vous allez venir ajouté
pour vous dire trouve extrêmement
facilement gradé est en train de shooter
c'est hyper impressionnant et après vous
arriver jusqu'au x 100 alors le x 100
c'est un petit peu what the fuck pas d
une fois de plus vous avez votre petit
première bourre pérennité du poisson
c'est pas d'avoir la meilleure qualité
parce que vous ne l'aurez pas qui est
très lisse et qui vient vraiment
chercher très loin le savez c'est un peu
comme ce que nous a montrée bon et avec
le p 30 points l'année dernière c'est
surtout l'innovation surtout la prouesse
est le fait de se dire ok je suis un
smartphone avec un smartphone alors qu
un téléobjectif qui complètement
hallucinant pour l'ajouter extrêmement
loin c'est ça qu'on est à chercher et
c'est ça qu'on vient voir c'est la
capacité qu'a samsung est à venir
innover on a vu les dernières que huawei
a mis une gifle un peu à tout le monde
avec son p 30 points la samsung avec le
samsung galaxy s 20 unis trappe
ils vont très très très loin j'ai hâte
de voir ce que nous proposera pas où et
avec elle le paie 40 pour l'être au ciel
c'est exceptionnel et évidemment les
photos avec eux une façon vous en ferai
rien absolument rien qualité pas d'elle
pour venir chercher deux points de
détail
vous allez voir c'est dingue ou encore
elton en quelques instants et à mon avis
va être bluffé il ya aussi des choses à
raconter du côté de la vidéo ça je vous
le montrer dans quelques instants et
notamment la stabilisation et vous vante
le truc comme étant une petite action
cam vous vous appuyez vous avez une
vraie stabilisation en vous savez
qu'avec moi la stabilisation va sa part
de ne pas perdre et je prends je le mets
comme ça
j'avoue le film et regardez je le tiens
une main vous savez que je tremble c'est
pas hyper évident et pourtant à l'image
il n'y a absolument rien c'est hyper
smooth ça ne bouge absolument pas ça
c'est vachement cool alors encore pire
avec la main gauche
le truc est quand même hyper bien
stabilisé à moi j'ai un petit peu
cherché l'histoire en tout cas quand
même super bien stabilisé ça marche ça
fait le taff et ça c'est cool que vous
soyez sur l' ultra grand-angle vous
passiez sur la caméra normale dans les
deux cas ça fonctionne et ça c'est bien
mais il ya un autre gros focus qui était
fait par samsung c'est le fait de
pouvoir venir filmer ici en 8k alors
globalement film en u15 spatiaux que
cela vous serve bien bien à grand-chose
voyez ce que vous allez venir filmer ici
en 24 images par seconde et absolument
pas en 25 30 60 images par seconde
une fois de plus on parle de la prouesse
technologique ont marre de la capacité
de le faire d'autant plus que samsung et
des écrans et des télés lui cas ils ont
aussi à lancer un service auquel ils
sont partenaires qui s'appelle explorer
et après vous avez plein de petits mode
vous avez un mode pro si vraiment vous
voulez vous amuser aller plus loin
panorama nourriture le mode nuit le
fameux menu qui vit caché ici saurez
plus dans le menu principal en disant
que le menu aujourd'hui on l'utilisé
quand même plutôt pas mal et qui en plus
une vraie valeur ajoutée le mode
portrait vidéo portrait vidéo pro bon il
ya plein de trucs rigolos qui sont pas
nécessairement extrêmement intéressant
mais je dirais que pour moi s'il faut
vraiment tenir là dessus c'est la
stabilisation en terme de vidéo les huit
cas ok mais vous l'utiliserez pas la
photo qui est bien avec le zoom jusqu'à
x 30 qui écoule voix sans c'est vraiment
histoire de se marrer le single take est
vraiment exceptionnel et ça c'est
vraiment la d2 ce smartphone c'est le
fait d'utiliser cette caméra là à fond
pour sortir des résultats qui sont
complètement incroyable on va donc
regarder les différentes photos là on
voit qu'on a la statue de la liberté au
loin sur le capteur principal on passe
sur l' ultra grand-angle et on va bien
se rapprocher
on va passer sur un zoom rapproche a
besoin tout doucement tout doucement
tout doucement et voyez l'on arrive sur
le zoom x 100 alors le froid sens il ya
un côté un petit peu rigolo mais
qualitativement c'est pas terrible
il faut reculer d'un pas en arrière pour
récupérer la qualité je pense que
jusqu'au x 30 ça va mais au delà c'est
pas terrible terrible on est sérieux
très grand-angle capteur principal et
ensuite on se rapproche on se rapproche
joaillier ce convoi 30 ça va ça fait le
taff et vous vous rapprochez os x sans
ça bave c'est pas extraordinaire caméra
de celle philips a fait le taf peut-être
un petit quelque chose là au niveau de
mon front sur les hautes lumières mais
ça va ça va franchement le rendu est
quand même très qualitatif capteur
principal ultra grand-angle et là on se
rapproche au zoom zoom zoom on zoome
jusqu'à arriver au foie sens où ça via
pas terrible ultra grand-angle caméra
principale on se rapproche on se
rapproche on se rapproche tout doucement
le one world trade center on se
rapproche et il en arrive au foie sans
le x 100 c'est vraiment what the fuck je
vous dise qu x 30
vous sortez un truc pieds bien au delà
de ça c'est pas génial ultra-grand-angle
caméra principale à garder on va se
rapprocher lors des franchement pas mal
on a quand même vachement ou mais c'est
pas mal
ils sont vraiment connaître les détails
de son visage eh bien voyez on se
rapproche et non pas vraiment les
détails du visage de la statue de la
liberté et ça c'est quand même assez
exceptionnel en plus que je trouve pas
masquer la colorimétrie est assez juste
lutte racontant des légèrement plus
jeune vous le voyez au niveau du ciel la
sinfonia protocole après que le capteur
principal sans rien et on se passe avec
le mode nourriture ça vient le réchauffé
je trouve un petit peu trop de la bonne
vie
nourriture américaine plein de calories
avec le mode nourriture sans le mot de
nourriture avec la bonne nourriture oui
ça vient quand même beaucoup beaucoup
réchauffer alors après à défaut vous
avez quand même une espèce de lumière
rouge pas trop trop loin donc bon c'est
bien aussi de l'éclairage et dans les
cei les photographes autonomie je trouve
que le rendu est quand même vachement
cool y ait une excellente gestion des
lumières très très très bon boulot fait
de la part de samsung là dessus on va
essayer différentes choses avec le
l'ultra grand temps que c'est un peu
moins cali mais ça fonctionne vous venez
vous rapprochez vous venez zoomer ça va
ça fait le taf je trouve qu'il ya un
résultat d quand même vachement
qualitatif samsung a fait un très très
très bon boulot sur son appareil photo
sur son mode nuit
si vous voulez la meilleure expérience
avec ali photo nuit il faut utiliser le
capteur principal luttera quand on est
un peu moins bon l'expo est un peu moins
bonne
ça fonctionne le zoom pourquoi pas mais
c'est pascal plus dingue mais par contre
avec le capteur principal
il ya un rendu qui est vraiment hypra
hypra qualitatif travaux de nuit et ça
ça fait toute la différence dans les
soins du très grand-angle et l'envié se
rapprocher avec le zoom on récupère un
petit peu de bruit ce qui n'est pas
anormal bats toi je vais vous parler du
mode portrait parce que moi le mode
portrait je trouve que le floutage et
plutôt bien le détourage est très très
bon derrière il ya de l'intelligence
artificielle ça fait le taf
par contre le temps il même au niveau
des cheveux ça fonctionne je trouve qui
est pas très très bon c'est la gestion
d'autres lumières la regardait d'un
visage est complètement cramé et sur
différentes photos réalisées avec les
modes portrait et bien la gestion de la
lumière est vraiment pas bonne la csq a
carrément de pire
le rendu est complètement cramé c'est
vraiment pour moi un des points faibles
au niveau de la photo
voilà de la vidéo où huit cas alors
ouais je trouve que ça fait le taf on a
un truc qui est pas mal je trouve que ça
vous servira pas à grand chose de venir
utiliser de la vidéo en 8k c'est beau on
peut venir croquer dedans on peut venir
zoomer dans l'image s'est malgré tout
assez bien stabilisé ce smartphone il a
aussi un truc vachement bien pour lui
son capteur d'empreintes digitales
ultrasonique est situé sous l'écran
alors été sorti l'année dernière avec le
s10 au début c'était pas terrible
il ya une mise à jour logicielle ça va
beaucoup mieux surtout ce qui est génial
avec son capteur d'empreintes digitales
que vous avez là et bien c'est qu'en
fait ils peuvent venir se mettre à jour
d'un point de vue logiciel à la
différence d'un capteur d'empreintes
digitales optique qui ne peut pas et là
dessus pour moi aussi ça marche
vachement bien ça déverrouille assez
rapidement donc ça c'est cool
non
semaine
m
une fois même
alors sur le samsung galaxy s 20 ultra
sur le modèle 128 go de stockage on est
à 1359 euros et sur le 512 on est à
milhas 559 euros c'est pas forcément
destiné à tout le monde le tarif est
très élevé mais c'est pour avoir ce qui
c'est une lutte chez samsung sur le très
haut de gamme
ça c'est à vous de faire votre tour un
smartphone qui est globalement plutôt
pas mal qui marche du tonnerre et d une
jambe mais times square
mandela ouais là on est plutôt bien pour
finir la vidéo comme ça moi j'aime bien
franchement je pense que nos points de
vue global ce que nous montrent ce
smartphone c'est l'innovation on n'est
pas sur ce mois faute de moyens on est
sur un smartphone est d'ailleurs assez
cher de la part de samsung rouler sur du
très haut de gamme mais c'est pas le
smartphone peut-être qu'il faut acheter
si vous voulez acheter un s20 et que
vous voulez pas mettre beaucoup d'argent
peut-être que le s20 plus sera fait pour
vous n'est pas grave dans quelques jours
je suis pas sûr pour moi ce smartphone
c'est vraiment ce qu'il y a une gueule
c'est la débauche de caractéristiques
techniques c'est le fait de pouvoir
filmer en lui qu'un c'est un zoom
périscopique fois sans ces 12 giga de
ram c'est le fs 3.0 vous voyez c'est une
débauche de fiches techniques samsung
s'il nous montre un peu les cojones
monstres ils ont dans le ventre mou sont
capables de faire bondir
on est là nous oubliez pas on est leader
on est numéro un et on n'est pas là pour
rien c'est le blues gros modèles il est
peut-être pas fait pour vous on se parle
quelques jours ds 20 et elle devint plus
en attendant vous invite à me dire tout
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire quand vous trouvez ce
samsung galaxy s 20 ultra ce qu'il vous
plaît
est ce qu'il vous plaît pas est ce que
vous trouvez intéressant où ils n'ont
tout simplement guéant bas en
commentaires que l'on se retrouve
extrêmement rapidement continue à parler
de teck parler de samsung mais parle
également de pas notre marque c'est
aussi plein de choses qui arrivent pas
d'événement c'est super cool regarder
j'en profite je reste ici à times square
avec des pubs de tous les côtés avec une
débauche d'écrans regarde hélas assez
emblématique ce bâtiment la garde et on
a même la pub de samsung qui est juste
là donc c'est grand c'est beau c'est
particulier
on aime pas il ya des écrans traversé
new york donc ça c'est cool
sur ce bout des gros bisous donne rendez
vous dès demain tu vas parler tech à
demain
[Musique]